bonsoir football encore une fois la une
de l'actualité avec le dernier match de
l'équipe de france dans la coupe du
monde l'argentine dernier match contre
la hongrie est décidément et rue des
problèmes jusqu'au bout les dirigeants
se sont trompés de maillots ils avaient
choisi des blancs des maillots blanc et
en hongrois aussi il a donc fallu
trouver d'autres maillots et le match a
commencé avec près de trois quarts
d'heure de retard dominique duvauchelle
oui vous êtes sans doute surpris de ne
pas reconnaître l'écouteur habituel de
l'équipe de france cette métamorphose
est dû à un malentendu rarissime à ce
niveau au moment d'entrer sur le terrain
les deux équipes se sont retrouvées avec
des maillots de même coloris et les
français ont dû revêtir les couleurs du
club local
malgré cet incident l'équipe de france
est en train de réussir sa
réhabilitation
après 40 minutes de jeu elle mène 1 but
à 0 regardez bien
la balle arrive à christian lopez un but
magnifique dans la lucarne à la 25e
minute de jeu
1 à 0 pour l'équipe de france et au
dernier aux dernières nouvelles on nous
apprend que l'équipe de france vient
d'acheter un deuxième but l'équipe de
france mène donc 2 but à zéro à mar del
plata contre laon de but de bordeaux
oui vous l'avez vu ce but de berdoll et
vous aurez de toute façon l'ensemble de
ces depuis donc un résumé de ce match
dans le spécial coupe du monde qui est
juste après le journal en marquant en
marge de ce match de football vous savez
que les dirigeants du football français
avaient entrepris des démarches auprès
des autorités argentines pour avoir des
informations sur le sort de 22 personnes
disparues dans ce pays ce matin ils ont
rendu public que le résultat de leur
démarche en publiant un communiqué où
l'on retrouve les noms de treize
français de cette personne possédant une
double nationalité et de deux citoyens
espagnols finalement assez peu de
détails dans ce communiqué sur le sort
actuel de ses fans de disparus philippe
rochot qui a rencontré certains membres
de leur famille a pu constater qu'ils
étaient déçus par ces informations ont
malheureusement ce communiqué nous
apporte aucune indication sur le sort
des personnes disparues
vous savez qu'il y à l'heure actuelle
onze disparus et que ce que nous avons
réclamé jusqu'à maintenant c'est que les
gens qui étaient disparues soit montré
qu'on sache de quoi ils sont inculpés
exactement et que s'ils sont coupables
qu'ils soient jugés selon les lois en
vigueur et pas avec des semblants de
quoi faire mais est ce que vous
confirmez l'exactitude des
renseignements qui sont sur ce
communiqué l'exactitude face et c'est
difficile à dire parce que si vous
prenez par exemple on va prendre un cas
concret le cas de michel péna sager
alors on voit ce michel guenassia a été
arrêté à vue lozère pour distribution de
tracts subversifs
moi je dis c'est faux parce que je
connais très bien michel benassaya c'est
le fils d'une de mes amies avec qui j'ai
travaillé à buenos aires
il a été arrêté sur dénonciation
il a été arrêté en plafond de buenos
aires un après midi il a été porté
disparu pendant trois semaines au bout
de trois semaines on a reçu un coup de
téléphone anonyme sa maman a reçu un
coup de téléphone anonyme disant que son
fils était en prison à vie j'allais voto
tristement célèbre et qu' elle pourrait
aller le voir
elle s'est présentée à la prison
effectivement son enfant était là et on
lui a jamais parlé de distribution de
tracts alors ça ça ne surprend un petit
peu d'autre part il a été arrêté
il a été arrêté en mars 60 cave on est
en étroit 20 après et je crois pas que
une distribution de tracts subversifs
puisse justifier c'est un jeune homme de
19 ans trois ans de prison dans des
conditions absolument déplorable il
domergue disparu entre le 20 et le 25
septembre 1970 à rosario avait une
activité politique d'opposition
monsieur c'est votre fils est ce que
cela vous apporte quelque chose de
nouveau sur le sort de votre fils de
lettres seule nouveauté c'est qu'il
reconnaît vraiment connaître mon fils on
dit que jusqu'à maintenant on disait
toujours pratiquement connaît par yves
domergue
maintenant que la coupe du monde de
football tire à sa fin que les
dirigeants vont rentrer est-ce que vous
avez un flux plus d'espoir un peu moins
d'espoir pour votre fils plutôt moins
que plus parce que j'ai très peur que
maintenant que la coupe du monde se
termine ce l'histoire de nos disparus
finissent dans un tiroir et que plus
personne n'en parle qu'il nous reste que
notre angoisse et rien de plus on n'est
pas en argentine c'est une des
réflexions entendues au petit matin
parmi les grévistes qui occupent l usine
renault de cléon au moment où les crs
entrer dans l'usiné
quelques minutes avant vers 3 heures du
matin après un dialogue avec la
direction et les forces de l'ordre
les grévistes avaient décidé d'évacuer
des locaux tout s'est passé sans
incident mais les syndicats appellent
maintenant tous les ouvriers de la régie
renault à passer à l'action
la nuit dernière à cléon à l'appel de la
direction plusieurs centaines de
policiers prenaient position devant
l'usiné occupée par les grévistes
après discussion avec la police les
ouvriers évacuer les usines sans
incident vers 3 heures les policiers y
pénétraient aussitôt comme un flins où
des employés accusés d' entrave à la
liberté du travail sont menacés de
licenciement c'est donc le durcissement
de la direction
même attitude chez les syndicats qui
protestent devant l'intervention
policière
cette politique de violence à l'égard
des salariés de toutes catégories de la
régie renault est une politique
d'intimidation massive répond aussi la
cfdt qui condamne l'intervention
policière et propose des grèves
fractionner la cgt elle laisse aux
usines le soin de se prononcer sur les
formes que revêtira le mouvement des
ratios la métallurgie cgt appelle
l'ensemble des travailleurs de la
métallurgie de france à une riposte
vigoureuse dès lundi matin dans toutes
les entreprises de façon à faire
obstacle à la répression et à l'appel
aux forces de police
la direction de renault dit s'il n'y a
plus d'occupation du sinn nous
négocierons alors il n'a plus est ce que
vous êtes prêts à négocier
nous allons juger le maçon au pied du
mur ça fait plusieurs semaines que nous
réclamons la reprise des négociations il
est temps je crois qu'elle observe cette
voie qui est la voix de la sagesse donc
vous négocierez nous nous sommes
toujours prêts à la négociation
manufrance le plan de redressement a été
acceptée ce matin par le conseil
d'administration de la firme stéphanoise
lundi après midi
monsieur gado clé le pdg de manufrance
pourra donc présenté ce plan un plan
qu'il a mis au point le présenter à
monsieur monory le ministre de
l'économie
il ya soir je vous le rappelle le maire
communiste de saint-etienne monsieur
sangle dolls avait expliqué que sa
municipalité accepter ce plan de
redressement mais sans l'approuver
peu de politiques en france aujourd'hui
à retenir simplement un nouveau texte
collectif signé par des femmes
communiste cette fois il est publié dans
le quotidien le monde
le parti communiste mis à nu par ces
femmes c'est le titre de ce texte qui
met en cause la politique du parti
communiste vis-à-vis des femmes au
lendemain de la fin du voyage du
président de la république en corse
et puis au lendemain de ses déclarations
de bastia où le chef de l'état a
expliqué qu'il était allergique au
chantage de la violence et qu'il
n'envisageait pas d'accroître les
pouvoirs de la région
les autonomistes corses par la voix
d'edmond simeoni ont retenu le blocage
politique qui apparaît dans toutes les
interventions de valéry giscard
d'estaing
le chef de l'état veut enfermer la corse
dans le carcan du droit commun distille
noël copains pour faire un dernier bilan
de ce voyage on peut constater avant
toute chose qu'il s'est bien passé
oui c'est la première marque que l'on
peut faire et au départ ce n'était pas
évident le président de la république
cours est en fait de risques le premier
c'était un accueil particulièrement
froid le second c'était des incidents le
long de sa route
or entre une certaine timidité ou
certaines réserves ajaccio le premier
jour une chaleur certaines bastia malgré
les manifestations qui avaient été
maintenus à l'écart
on peut dire que ce voyage s'est bien
passé il est vrai que le risque était
calculé les vrai aussi que des mesures
importantes avaient égalisé avant et
pendant le voyage
mais tout compte fait par rapport à ce
qui aurait pu arriver c'est un élément
positif de swire voient leur bilan
concret maintenant mais le bilan concret
c'est essentiellement la série de
mesures que le prétendant république
annoncé lui-même ajaccio jeudi et que
nous avons d'ailleurs
et d'étayer ce soir là mais le fait
dominant du voyage c'est le choix
politiques affirmer très clairement par
le président de la république tout au
long de son parcours sous les ce choix
politique c'est le refus d'une évolution
sur le plan des institutions pas de
statut particulier pour la corse d'une
façon plus générale pas de pouvoir
régional dans les régions françaises
en somme aucun pas aucune satisfaction
n'est donnée aux autonomistes ni même à
ceux qui se trouvent un peu dans une
certaine mouvance autonomiste c'est pour
ça qu'il ya cette réaction que vous
citiez tout à l'air c'est traction qui
parle de blocage politique alors toute
la question est maintenant de savoir si
les mesures économiques sociales
culturelles etc sont de nature à mettre
fin rapidement au malaise corse
et si vous laissez le sont de nature à
faire que lille que la corse cesse
d'être ce que le président giacobbi
président du conseil régional et disait
avec humour l'autre jour la corse une
île entourée d'eau entourée de monopole
est entourée des préjugés et puis le
politiquement vous pensez que ce voyage
ait une importance particulière pour le
chef de l'ugtt a et b soul et ceux qui a
frappé je crois les ceux qui ont suivi
ce voyage qui ont suivi le président de
la république c'est cette image qu'il a
donné de lui-même
l'image d'un président vraiment sûr de
lui on al'impression qu'avec ce voyage
en corse comme d'ailleurs avec les
initiatives qu'il a prises récemment en
afrique
il est en train de transformer ce que
l'on appellerait en terme commercial son
image de marque et ceci n'est pas sans
importance sur la vie politique
française en particulier à l'intérieur
même de la majorité où monsieur chirac
est le rpr avait su se donner le
privilège
apparaître comme étant les plus musclés
les plus déterminés l'image du président
de la république martelant ses phrases
nortel ans est mort hier sur la grande
place de bastia en présence d'ailleurs
du régiment de légionnaires qui rentrait
du shaba et bien cette image je crois
que ses adversaires et ses rivaux
éventuels devront en garde et le devons
en garder le souvenir ils peuvent
discuter son attitude ils peuvent
contester ses décisions mais le
président de la république ne peut plus
être accusés comme naguère de fragilise
ainsi noël copains à l'occasion de la
visite de valéry giscard d'estaing en
corse le 2e rep régiment étranger de
parachutistes a été citée à l'ordre de
l'armée par le ministre de la défense
magnifique régiment dit la citation qui
a réalisé avec succès l'opération
aéroportée de protection et de sauvetage
des populations à col v 250
parachutistes français sont restés sur
place à kolwezi
il devrait quitter le pays dans les
jours qui suivent pour être remplacés
par des soldats 17 pays africains qui
vont former la force commune
d'intervention chargée de défendre la
région minière du shaba là où se trouve
kolwezi
le président du zaïre le général mobutu
a expliqué aujourd'hui que ces soldats
africains ne resteront pas longtemps eux
non plus dans la région ils seront
bientôt remplacés à leur tour par
l'armée zaïroise un remplacement qui
inquiète non seulement les européens
mais également la population noire
locale chacun se souvient là bas de la
carence de ses soldats zaïrois au moment
de l'attaqué rebelle katangaise mais
également des bavures qui ont conduit
bon nombre de blessés dans les hôpitaux
de la région
dans ce bloc opératoire de l'hôpital de
lubumbashi au chabat chirurgiens
anesthésistes et infirmiers travaillent
sans relâche depuis plus de deux
semaines ils essaient de sauver les
victimes civils blessés par les balles
perdues à kolwezi mais également et
volontairement selon certains
témoignages par celle de l'armée
zaïroise quinze jours après la reprise
de la cité minière par les parachutistes
français et le contrôle des quartiers
noirs par les forces aillent roises
certains de ces blessés se sont confiés
aux personnels hospitaliers
leurs témoignages sont accablants 2
des l'usiné cami mais à la quinine la
ivy league en deux semaines quand vous
lisez comme à cazideroque où il se
rendait au travail un uniforme pour
aller se renseigner si on travaille ces
jours là mais vu notre attaque bas comme
une base militaire en sibérie et oise il
a rencontré trois militaires veille
mais vu que c'est grand nassima au corps
est belle il croit qu'il est elle une
forme et on a traité des rebelles et on
l'a tiré dessus
cet enfant était blessé chez lui à son
domicile de sa mère est hospitalisée ici
dans notre service de chirurgie elle
présente elle d'une fracture ouverte de
la cheville et cet enfant que vous voyez
présente une fracture ouverte du fémur
que nous ayons que nous essayons de
stabiliser par un tuteur externe
c'est un accident qui remonte à plus de
dix jours et que les avions français
transall avec le service sanitaire
français nous ont amenés ici à
lubumbashi il ya deux jours aux dires de
la mère il s'agirait des forces zaïroise
qui aurait tiré sur elle et sur sa
famille dans toutes les cités de
lubumbashi
les gens sont au courant des vexations
ou exactions que la remise est loin ça
commises sur des civils et même ici à
gauche il est connu que des exactions
sont commises quotidiennement
cela entraîne au sein du peuple une
déception énorme qui ne demande qu'à
déclic pour exploser les bavures de
l'armée zaïroise à kolwezi sont
maintenant connus de tous le chat bas
ils ont déclenché la colère dans les
cités certains habitants ont été
rançonné d'autres a battus ou blessés à
kolwezi
quand les militaires et les rois ont
repris le contrôle des quartiers noirs
après la fuite des rebelles un
intellectuel 0 analysent la situation
pour lui une grande partie de la
population a épousé la cause des
rebelles après l'invasion de la ville
parce que les gens les lunda notamment
sont opposés au régime de kinshasa et
qu'ils veulent un changement la faim et
la misère les ont poussé l'armée à mon
avis n'a pas toujours été à la hauteur
de sa tâche et mon dieu vous trouver
parmi des militaires des gens assez
vexant
vous comprenez que devant la faim devant
les vexations
il est possible que devant une force
étrangère qu'on est l'illusion d'un
changement d'une situation meilleure que
celle dans laquelle on se trouve
les européens aujourd'hui quelques
bonnes raisons de ne pas se sentir en
sécurité dans ces villes minières du
shaba l'exemple de kolwezi les carences
de l'armée zaïroise de ralliement des
lunda à la cause des ex gendarme
qu'attend gay comme les événements
passés au zaïre ont de quoi les faire
réfléchir
leur peur s'était apaisée avec la
présence des parachutistes français et
belges mais le deuxième raid aquitaine
chabat et les commandes aux belges vans
wheels bien sûr la force interafricaine
les remplacent et doit assurer la
sécurité
mais si les rebelles reviennent à
lubumbashi où ailleurs comme à kolwezi à
quatre ou dix mille contre 15 cents
que se passera-t-il que fera l'armée
zaïroise que fera la population noire
les européens peuvent tout craindre
aussi bien un retour des rebelles d'un
éventuel
d'extrême droite et d'extrême gauche qui
manifestaient dans le centre de la ville
les élections pour le parlement européen
c'est dans un an exactement
et pour mieux préparer cette première
consultation le mouvement européen
organisation française a organisé
aujourd'hui une mini manifestation pour
l'ouverture d'une campagne d'information
à paris professeur leprince ringuet le
président de ce mouvement européen est
descendu lui même dans la rue pour
distribuer des tracts et des journaux
les chauffards de la mer trois nouveaux
navires ont été arraisonnés cette
semaine par la marine nationale parce
qu'il circulait à contresens sur la
route des pétroliers au large d'ouessant
dans le finistère les fautifs sont un
cargo norvégien un cubain et un libérien
au total 16 navires ont été déroutés sur
brest depuis la nouvelle réglementation
décidé après la catastrophe de l'amoco
cadiz et puis en suède
un incendie dramatique la nuit dernière
dans le principal hôtel de boras une
petite ville dans le sud ouest du pays
dans la partie supérieure de l'hôtel il
y avait une boîte de nuit où 150 jeunes
était en train de danser ça a été la
panique bilan provisoire 22 morts et
plus de 50 blessés quand l'incendié
s'est déclaré vers 3 heures du matin au
rez de chaussée de cet hôtel 150 jeunes
gens dans ciel intérieur ils fêtaient la
fin de l'année scolaire
ce fut bien sûr l'affolement certains se
précipitèrent vers le grand escalier du
stade hôtel mais les flammes qui
montaient du rez de chaussée et la fumée
épaisse les arrêté plusieurs personnes
prises de panique tentèrent de trouver
refuge dans les toilettes un piège nous
l'on retire à huit corps carbonisés un
témoin raconte j'ai vu deux personnes
transformé en torche air se jeter du 3e
et ac
selon les premiers éléments d'enquêté
c'est une lampe qui en explosant aurait
mis le feu à des rideaux voilà pour
l'origine du sinistre maintenant
pourquoi dans deux victimes
et bien selon le capitaine des pompiers
le stade hôtel qui date de 1907 et qui a
été récemment rénovés ne possédait pas
des issues de secours suffisante pour
permettre à elle seule
l'évacuation complète de l'établissement
la page sportive de notre journal
maintenant avec pour commencer un record
du monde en athlétisme celui du 100 m
haies a été battue par la polonaise rap
steen nouveau record 12 secondes 48
centièmes le football la coupe du monde
n'a pas détourné les fanas de la course
automobile de leur droit chemin vers le
circuit du mans pratiquement autant de
monde que les années passent et sinon
plus pour le départ des 24 heures cet
après midi il faut dire que le soleil
était de la fête
il nous sommes ici sur le circuit du
mans au moment où le départ vient d'être
lancée celle alpine renault au numéro 1
celle de jacques beaulieu et de patrick
de payet qui prend la tête immédiatement
devant celle conduite par jacky ickx et
henri pescarolo les voitures viennent de
descendre maintenant derrière la courbe
dunlop elles vont affecter laisse du
tertre rouge sur la ligne de départ
la première place était occupée par la
voiture de jacky ickx tandis que jean
pierre jabouille et patrick deux pays
avaient dû attendre la seconde journée
des essais pour réussir à se placer dans
le premier tour et les voitures attaque
maintenant la ligne droite des
hunaudières cette fameuse ligne droite
des hunaudières qui pose un certain
nombre de problèmes du reste à l'issue
des essais et bien non mais sommes
maintenant en direct et nous suivons une
voiture qui revient au stand le
classement amateur était le suivant à la
première place la spin l'alpine renault
de pironi jean pierre jaussaud suivi par
à un tour par une autre alpine celle de
jean pierre jarlier de derek bell la
première porsche un tour également des
leaders était celle de bob wollek et de
jürgen barth tandis que lépine de tête
celle celle qui était en tête au moment
du départ de la course celle de jean
pierre jabouille de patrick de payet
n'est qu'en quatrième position mais il
semble actuellement que cette alpines
sont en train de faire le forcing pour
essayer de rattraper
temps perdu nous voyons ici d'enfance
qui s'est arrêté à son stand il s'agit
en fait un arrêt tout à fait classique
il s'agit de refaire les plains ceux que
l'on aperçoit sur l'avant de la voiture
nous suivons les leaders dans la ligne
droite des hunaudières cinquième au
classement également et c'est
intéressant c'est la fameuse moby dick
sayer alors que sur l'écran vous voyez
que la cinquième c'est la 5e position
est occupée par une renault sa de radio
j ai de très claire de la force
moby dick les positions maintenant
semble acquise de toute façon on
approche de la le temps a fraîchi
maintenant et on a mis des programmes
est dans les voitures voilà la voiture
la porsche qui vient de passer devant
les stands à des suivis par une
c'est une amie raf qui s'arrête à son
stand maintenant je vous disais donc
la course a pris maintenant son allure
de croisière à par jalousie et de payet
qui semble faire le forcing pour essayer
de regagner quelques places mais nous ne
sommes à l'heure actuelle qu'à 4 après
le départ et la course dure 24 heures
nous ferons un nouveau point dans notre
journal de 13 heures demain qui peut
battre le suédois borg
c'est la grande question que se posent
tous ceux qui ont suivi les
internationaux de france de tennis à
roland garros depuis près de deux
semaines et la demi finale qu'il a
remporté cet après-midi en écrasant
l'italien barazutti ne résout rien dans
cette affaire
demain ce sera donc la finale le grand
choc borg rencontrera l'argentin vilas
tenant du titre lille à skis à lui
éliminé facilement l'américain stockton
cet après midi pauvre barazutti ne
s'attendait sûrement pas à être ainsi 6
0 6 1 6 0 un score de tour éliminatoire
sûrement pas de demi finale alors que
cherche bjorn borg
jamais il n'a été aussi dominateurs mais
il ne se refuse aucun effort et se
bagarre sur toutes les balles depuis le
début de ses internationaux il n'a pas
encore concédé un set
le fait de ne pas jouer trop têtu
sud-américain taner qui réussit à aller
jusqu'au tie break dans la troisième
manche pour la perte bien évidemment à
22 ans le suédois est encore un jeune
tennisman
s'il continue sur sa lancée il ne
restera bientôt plus grand chose pour
les autres qui devront se résoudre à
n'être que finaliste est rarement sinon
jamais vainqueur
domination qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celle que les verts l'australien
exerçant en 1969 et demain sur le court
central
guillermo vilas risque bien d'être une
nouvelle fois victime de la boulimie de
victoire qui anime bjorn borg à
guillermo vilas qui de plus cette année
n'a pas été aussi incisif qu'en 77 dans
la rencontre qui l'opposait cet après
midi à dick stockton qu'il a semblé
retrouver une partie de ses moyens
notamment à la volée n'a été vraiment
difficultés que sur les services
gratuits sont américains alors demain
que va-t-il se passer
eh bien on peut sans trop s'avancer
pronostiqué une victoire du suédois
c'est l'interrogation combien de cette
ville as le site aura-t-il la grande
saison des lauriers maintenant n'auriez
dans le sens de récompenses et non point
dans le sens potager avec tout d'abord
les résultats du 21e festival du film
d'entreprise à biarritz
le grand prix a été décerné au film de
la compagnie générale maritime les
listes rouges et c'est notre président
directeur général monsieur maurice
ulrich qui a eu l'honneur de remettre le
grand prix de ce festival aux lauréats
dans le commanditaire et la redoute le
monde et pg le réalisateur jacques alain
rey le commanditaire total compagnie
française des pétroles producteurs film
de la maîtrise réalisateur claude
loiseau pour maurice ulrich et les
membres des différents jurys de ce
festival de biarritz il s'agissait de
choisir entre quelques 130 films
présentés par une centaine des
producteurs c'est dire que pour voir
tous ces films en quelques jours il faut
passer le plus clair de son temps dans
les salles obscures et ce genre de
marathon rappelle bien sûr les festivals
de cannes de venise ou d'ailleurs mais
la ressemblance s'arrête là
ici il n'ya pas de starlettes il ya une
grande vedette mia trouve pas sur la
plage ces grandes vedettes c'est
l'entreprise
quand une entreprise décide d'expliquer
quelque chose à ses clients même à son
personnel autrefois le faisait une note
du papier aujourd'hui une image est
devenue reine et une telle entreprise
fait faire un film
si son film tournée l'an dernier en
france pour 12 milliards de centimes de
chiffre d'affaires le film d'entreprise
a cessé d'être une activité de promotion
un peu marche
c'est devenu un véritable secteur
économique
et quant à la qualité cinématographique
de ce qui a été présenté ici il suffit
pour s'en convaincre de regarder un
simple extrait du film qui a été primée
aujourd'hui donne allemagne à la
malaisie du danemark à la corée de la
france à hong kong de la suède aux
philippines
le conteneur par sa souplesse
d'utilisation est devenu pour chaque
pays symbole de productivité de richesse
nationale de produits de qualité
à cet instant précis le dernier
conteneurs vient se placer sur le pont
du sel en dia
pour le judo en dia qui approchent
maintenant de suez
il est 14 heures 8 heures se sont
écoulées depuis son passage à heath
malien au petit matin
autre lauréat pour un autre prix daniel
boulanger auteur d'un recueil de
nouvelles intitulé l' enfant de bohème
paru chez gallimard
il a reçu le prix du livre inter en 1978
tous les ans un jury d'auditeurs
attribue ce prix un auteur pour
promouvoir la lecture en france daniel
boulanger donc cette année
rapidement la météo pour demain sur
l'ensemble du pays il fera généralement
beau et chaud seules les régions
méditerranéennes les alpes et le sud du
massif central auront du temps lourd et
orageux avec des averses sur le relief
partout ailleurs après dissipation des
brumes matinales la journée donc sera
bien ensoleillé football donc je vous
rappelle que vous avez un rendez-vous
immédiatement après ce journal et après
également une page de publicité
vous avez rendez vous avec daniel cazals
hervé duthu pour un spécial coupe du
monde vous aurez là tous les buts de
l'équipe de france marqué par l'équipe
de france dans le match contre la
hongrie
il y a beaucoup de buts puisque l'équipe
de france pour l'instant mènent de trois
buts à un
il n'y a pas de journal de 23h ce soir
j'aurais donc le plaisir de vous
retrouver à 13 heures demain ce sera
notre prochain rendez vous avec
l'information sur antenne 2 et puis pour
terminer ce journal je voudrais vous
offrir les images un peu particulière de
dominos tamponneurs sur les images qu'on
vient de recevoir des etats-unis
c'est elle le record du monde une
tentative pour le battre le record du
monde de dominos tamponneurs bob specta
junior avait déjà battu le record avec
cinquante mille dominos posé
verticalement sur le sol il s'agit de
les renverser
cette fois il essayait de le battre le
record avec 100 mille dominos
c'est pas très utile mais c'est très
spectaculaire je vous souhaite une très
belle soirée sur antenne 2